Hello everybody, welcome to the last section of the book so I hope you learned a lot from this and you don't even need to read this because you have it down path
That's fantastic and this section we're just going to wrap everything up. I know I've hit this a lot of times but it's super important the three stages of life.
A cute line that window of opportunity to treat it with an antibiotic, a chronic line that window of opportunity to treat it with a nutraceutical that is going to stimulate an immune response.
So these are typically immune stimulators that you're going to use. And the patients that come to us are autoimmune disease line.
They're already in autoimmune disease. You can be TH2 stimulant, TH2 dominant autoimmune line but it's very very rare. Almost all of them are TH1 dominant. That's why they have such destruction and people can even die from this.
So TH1 dominant make sure you're not using TH1 stimulants. You're not taking any TH1 stimulants and you'll see the list of those in the book.
You're using something other to try to kill the line. Again, we use energy medicine and we use the right machine. So super important that you use the right type of right machine. We use the true right.
Very important that you have a program correctly. Please do this. We even will sell rifes that have generic program on them that they will hurt themselves with through our office.
So you can check out our website and call our clinic about that too.
Brain therapy is very important as well. That's part of our program if you come in and use us for your service.
Again, we've hit this over and over tree cute line as soon as possible with antibiotics. If you're not yet in the autoimmune phase, you can try immune stimulants.
If you use of immune stimulants, it's not solved your problems. There's a pretty good chance you're already in stage 3.
Or if your disease process is quite aggressive, you're probably already in stage 3 and you're most likely TH1 dominant.
Or if previous TH1 stimulants have worsened your symptoms, you're in stage 3. If you're in stage 3, just contact us.
Alright, I hope this was a blessing. Know that we'll be praying for you regardless of whether you ever become a patient or not or here for you.
So I hope this has helped you.
Constantly be looking at our website for updates. If I downloaded this book, you're on our newsletter list.
If you choose never to receive anything from us again, make sure you just opt out. Otherwise I'm constantly updated with new different ideas and protocols because that's just how I am.
So you'll always be here and for less.
Alright, God bless and I hope to hear from you soon.